In Ancient Rome tampons were made of wool,
Indonesians used vegetable fibers and Japanese
women used rolled up paper. The first commercial
tampons were launched in the 1930s and today
women use up to 12,000 menstrual hygiene products
per lifetime. But is there a better option?
Should you stop wearing tampons?
Despite being a completely normal biological
process that half the population faces, menstruation
is often taboo. The menstrual cycle begins
every 28 days on average, and repeats from
puberty to menopause.
Every month, in response to the reproductive
hormones progesterone and estrogen, the lining
of the uterus grows and thickens preparing
for a potential pregnancy; however, if pregnancy
doesn’t occur, progesterone drops and the
thickened lining sheds.
The menstrual flow is a combination of this
uterine lining and blood from the arteries
in your uterus, which is a unique trait as
few other species menstruate at all. In every
other mammal other than humans, primates,
bats and the adorable elephant shrew, the
endometrium only thickens in response to getting
pregnant.
During menstruation, 30-90ml of fluid is lost,
and 81% of women use tampons as the primary
method to absorb this blood, at times in combination
with pads. Tampons use exceptionally absorbent
materials like cotton and rayon that interact
strongly with water. And while cotton and
rayon are biodegradable, the rest of the tampon
isn’t, contributing to 300lbs of waste in
a woman’s lifetime.
The materials also provide an environment
that the bacteria staphylococcus like, which
can lead to a rare but potentially fatal disease
known as Toxic Shock Syndrome. As menstrual
blood adds neutralizing proteins to the vagina,
which is normally more acidic, it’s ability
to kill bacteria is reduced. In 1983 more
than 2,200 cases of Toxic Shock Syndrome were
reported to the CDC, but by 1997 there were
only 5 cases. This decrease is attributed
to education about tampons, like the need
to change it at least every 8 hours and using
the lowest absorbency for your flow. On top
of this, tampons can lead to vaginal dryness
and breakage in the skin, leaving you prone
to further infection.
On average women spend close to $100 on tampons
and pads a year, which are often taxed as
‘luxury goods’ despite being a basic necessity.
Protests have influenced governments like
Canada to remove the ‘Tampon Tax’ but
in many lower income nations, the high price
of tampons causes girls to miss school. In
South Africa, 9 million girls ages 13-19 miss
school because of a lack of menstrual hygiene
products or facilities to change them throughout
the day.
One alternative solution to tampons is a menstrual
cup. It’s a non-absorbent reusable barrier
cup that collects blood. The cost of the cup
is significantly less than tampons, and is
reusable for multiple years. It can also be
worn for 12 hours, meaning women can change
it home, as opposed to school or work, and
it creates substantially less environmental
waste. In a study where women aged 19-40 who
had previously used tampons as their main
method, were given menstrual cups for 3 cycles,
and 91% said they would continue to use the
cup and recommend it to others despite the
learning curve.
Period blood could also save your life! Scientists
are developing diagnostic tests that women
can use at home to monitor early signs of
cancer, reproductive diseases, STIs and endometriosis
using their menstrual blood. Additionally,
stem cells found in menstrual blood are more
powerful than those found in bone marrow.
These stem cells can differentiate into nine
different types of cells, meaning period blood
might provide a potentially unlimited, easily
collected, inexpensive and without ethical
dilemma, source of stem cells for regenerative
medicine!
From gross and taboo, to normal, to potentially
life saving, periods are pretty cool! Period.
If you want to learn interesting scientific
hacks to minimize physical pain, and emotional
pain during your period, head over to my channel
Ask Kimberly. Or you can check out my other
videos, where I tackle all kinds of relationship
issues as a relationship expert and a therapist.
Thanks to my brother Mitch for having me on
the channel and subscribe for more weekly
science videos!